Three,
two,
one titles say right.
That's it.
What's up,
Nina?
How are you?
Hi,
good to be here.
Thanks for doing this.
Appreciate it.
Good to be here.
That's a big fat surprise.
What's the big fat surprise
that better meet and t's do not cause
heart disease.
That saturated fat doesn't cause heart
disease.
That fat doesn't make you fat.
Low Fat Diet doesn't make you healthy.
That's my book.
Yeah.
That's very controversial.
Pull this sucker up real close to you.
Alright,
there we go.
Right there.
Beautiful.
I'm very controversial in this day and
age.
It was even more controversial when the
book came out,
which isn't a 2014,
but you know,
we've seen,
uh,
an almost complete sea change on this
subject.
Not at the expert level,
but you know,
there's a real groundswell,
a in a change of thinking.
Um,
I think,
I think in part really triggered by my
book,
um,
which really laid out all the arguments
for how do we come to believe that
saturated fat is bad for health.
Why do we believe animal fats are bad?
Why do you believe?
Why do we believe they cause heart
disease?
Um,
and really tells that whole story of how
we started down this path,
believing that fat and cholesterol cause
heart disease,
make you sick,
caused cancer,
make you fat.
And um,
it's a wild story.
It's just an incredible story of the
politics,
the personalities.
It really is a story more about politics
than about science.
Did you feel vindicated when the New
York Times article came out where it
showed that the sugar industry had
bribed these scientists to lie about
data and falsified data that showed that
saturated fat was the cause of heart
disease instead of sugar?
Because that was fairly recently,
right?
It was after your book.
That was.
And you know,
that's a small part of the story.
I mean,
I have documents in my book,
there's,
there's maybe a hundred different
documents that you can find where
companies are trying to sway the
interest is they're trying to pay off
scientists basically.
There's so much money going into
nutrition science.
We really,
it's amazing how little people know
about how much nutrition science is
funded by the food industry.
And that was one small example where
Harvard scientists had received money
from the sugar industry.
And what the,
um,
this article contended is that,
that's what pushed them to blame fat and
not sugar for heart disease.
Actually don't believe that that's what
happened in that particular case for
those Harvard scientists in 19 fifties
because I studied them extensively,
you know,
for my book,
I read like,
well,
it took me nine years and I read like
10,000 scientific papers.
So I knew the work of those Harvard
scientists.
I knew everything they had written.
One of them is named mark hegsted,
who is very influential.
And the reality for him and his,
his colleagues was that they truly 100
percent believe that fat and saturated
fat and cholesterol caused heart
disease.
And they had believed it.
They had believed it for more than a
before the sugar industry came along
with that proposition for them.
They really believed those early
scientists were true.
Um,
they,
they were not corrupt.
They are,
they were actually not corrupted by
industry.
They were true believers.
And one of the things that my book
explorers is this phenomenon that
happens,
happened then happened today,
where scientists,
they come to fall in love with their
beliefs.
You know,
they fall in love with their own
hypothesis.
So
humans,
it's a problem with humans,
right?
So this is what we all do.
We all,
we fall in love with an idea,
we believe something and we only see
things that confirm it and we kind of
ignore everything that contradicts it.
Well in science,
what scientists are supposed to do,
what they're taught to do is to not
behave in a human way.
They're taught to rigorously distrust
their beliefs.
They're taught to try to find every way
to shoot down their own hypothesis.
That's the job of being a scientist.
That's why they seem so cold and
dispassionate or show to us mere humans.
But in the case of nutrition science,
that didn't happen.
They fell in love with their idea.
It was like a favored child.
They,
all they did was try to find evidence to
support it.
They Cherry pick the evidence again and
again,
and they completely ignored or actively
even suppressed any information that
contradicted their ideas.
So this scientist,
mark hegsted at Harvard,
he and his favorite colleague Ancil
keys,
who is from the University of Minnesota,
they would actually bully and kind of
stomp on scientists who came up with
contradictory information.
They would actually suppress stuff.
They W,
and this is still going on today,
which is what makes it such an
interesting story.
I mean today,
it's the same phenomenon in nutrition
science.
This is the way nutrition science
started and it's,
it's the legacy that continues today,
which is that I any papers to the
contrary,
you know,
hard to get them published,
hard to get them into,
discussed,
hard to get them presented at expert
meetings.
Um,
and it's,
it's been driven by people who are
really married to their hypothesis about
what a healthy diet is.
So you feel like what happened was the
sugar industry came along and they found
these people that already had beliefs
that aligned with what they were trying
to sell.
Right?
So maybe they weren't even so neck or so
corrupt,
like maybe they've said,
oh,
well these scientists know more than us,
just pay them to get this research out.
He knew you can't blame industries for
trying to protect their products.
Right?
Every industry doesn't.
But I mean it's just what industry does.
And you know,
if there.
There was another story out recently
about how the sugar industry didn't
pursue research they had done that
seemed to show that sugar causes cancer.
Well,
I mean,
if you're the sugar industry,
like what is your obligation to keep
going?
I mean,
I'm not saying that,
you know,
they're new angels,
but we shouldn't expect corporations to
be angels.
What,
what you do expect is for your
scientists to behave in a principled
way,
right?
That's what we should expect.
Yeah.
I mean when it gets to a certain way,
I think if you look at cigarettes,
for instance,
in the debate industry,
like there's a large market for
something we know kills people.
I mean,
you don't have to lie about it.
You can have a warning on the label and
it still makes billions of dollars a
year.
Tell everybody,
hey,
this is definitely going to give you
cancer.
Keep smoking it.
And they'll go,
okay.
And they'll buy it.
They'll keep buying it.
So it's not really that you need to lie
about things,
you really don't.
I mean,
people are more than willing,
as long as it hits the right buttons and
switches in their brain and their
receptors,
they're more than willing to put their
health in danger for some temporary
mouth.
Pleasure.
Yeah.
And this kind of goes to the subject
that is debated in the food world,
which is,
you know,
how much should the government be
telling people what to eat?
Right?
Right.
So there are people who think,
you know,
they believe sugars like tobacco,
if you eat it,
you will probably,
if you get a lot of sugar,
you are much more likely to get diabetes
and heart disease.
I mean,
I think that even if you had a lot of
refined carbohydrates or maybe even if
you eat too many carbohydrates,
period,
you're more likely to get diabetes and
heart disease.
And become obese,
so you should,
but people like it.
And then there's also people that are on
a plant based diet,
like my friend Eddie,
who you just met is right before you,
uh,
who's a Vegan now he's been a Vegan,
I,
we say a couple of years,
three years,
I think you said he's waiting many
carbohydrates and he's admitting it and
talking about it,
not,
not exactly knowing how to fix his,
his cravings and urges,
you know,
if you're on a completely plant based
diet,
it's really hard to just go all fats and
get the proper amount of saturated and
unsaturated fats in your diet.
Yeah,
I mean,
so people aren't Vegan diets for many
reasons.
Um,
and,
and that's their own personal choice.
The reality is that,
um,
the,
you know,
there's a large body of rigorous
research by that I mean randomized
controlled clinical trials and thousands
of people showing that a diet higher in
fat and low in carbohydrates leads to
better outcomes in terms of diabetes,
obesity,
heart disease.
Those are the biggies,
right?
Uh,
and so lowering carbohydrates is the way
to reverse out of those diseases.
If you're on a Vegan diet,
it's just very hard to do that in a low
carb way,
you know,
what do you eat is your,
your source of protein and fat.
There's just,
there are some plant fats,
you can have a lot of coconut oil and a
lot of avocado,
but you know,
it just becomes hard.
Like what do you,
what do you put on your plate for dinner
every night?
You know,
like if you eat meat,
you have to meat.
I mean that used to be just at the
center of the dinner plate,
but it's,
it's hard on a Vegan Diet.
Other thing that's very hard to a Vegan
diet is staying.
You need to be really careful about
nutritional supplements.
Um,
and because you cannot get a,
get all the nutrients that you need
naturally from the foods that you're
eating.
And also some of those nutrients are not
as bio digestible,
meaning your body doesn't absorb them as
easily.
Like iron from spinach is not as
absorbable as iron from meat.
So.
So it's hard.
It's hard to stay healthy on that diet.
Yeah.
That is the big misconception right?
When you look at the total amount of
iron or protein or anything at a plant
based diet is the bio availability of
that people.
It's less and people don't understand
that.
So when people do like hold up charts
that show,
hey,
you can get a cup of Broccoli and that
as the same amount of protein as a
cheeseburger.
Oh No,
it doesn't.
It really doesn't.
It might on paper.
But in terms of how your body absorbs
it,
it's not equal.
No.
All right.
You know,
another example is carrots.
I supposed to give you vitamin A,
right?
But carrots don't get.
They give you a precursor to vitamin a
called carotinoids.
Can it convert into vitamin a?
Not that efficiently.
Most people can't convert that
efficiently so they're not getting the
kind of vitamin a they need.
And what does vitamin A come from?
What food sources?
You know,
I don't know if top of my head and a
good source of vitamin C,
source animal.
Let's see.
I think you'd get it.
Pork Vitamin A.
I'm sorry,
I should know that,
but I.
But,
but you can get all the vitamins and
minerals and nutrients that you need
from animal foods,
um,
and you'd have to,
we'd have to eat this entire studio full
of spinach to get them out of iron that
you need and you can get that amount of
iron in,
in,
you know,
in a few ounces of meat.
So another one of the.
I'm sorry,
can you know,
the other thing is that in order to get
protein,
like if you can get your,
you can get your protein from being.
Say you have to have to get a complete
protein that's,
you have beans and rice,
but in order to get um,
you know,
let's say 100 grams of protein,
you need to eat like a thousand calories
of beans and rice versus say a couple
hundred calories of meat.
Okay.
So don't hold me to those numbers,
but I'm just telling you,
eat a lot more calories to get the same
amount of protein.
Yeah.
So for a day's worth of protein,
you're saying obviously wouldn't want
100 grams of protein in a single serving
preferred two days worth of protein.
Right?
You're probably gonna eat or an
exorbitant amount of beans and rice or
Broccoli or whatever the hell else are
trying to eat.
What are like iron is a big one,
right?
I know I have a few friends that are
Vegan or have been Vegan and that was a,
an issue with them was,
was iron.
Yeah.
I mean I was a vegetarian for over 25
years and I was always anemic and I take
iron pills and that didn't work.
And you just,
you know,
heme iron,
which is the favorite kind for
absorption,
is only available from animal sources.
And principally red meat.
White meat is chicken as relatively poor
in nutrients,
pouring iron too.
So,
you know,
the most nutrient dense food on the
planet is liver,
um,
which nobody is used to eating anymore
and we all think it's disgusting.
But
I like it too.
But you know,
know grandparents generation,
they had,
you know,
they had chopped liver or whatever.
They bring onions,
onions,
and that's very nutrient dense,
but we stopped eating it because it's
high in cholesterol.
So,
so these are the consequences of having.
What we did was,
this was my book is about,
but it's,
you know,
we started,
it started in 1961.
We basically,
the American Heart Association was the
first organization to say don't eat
saturated fat and cholesterol to avoid a
heart attack.
And that was based on,
at the time really weak evidence,
uh,
you know,
something called an observational study
can show an association but not
causation.
And um,
you know,
there were just enormous unintended
consequences at the time.
So actually this Harvard scientists
markets hegsted this was,
you know,
he was one of the people behind this and
he said,
we,
we imagined the benefits will be great
and we cannot imagine what the,
uh,
what the,
if they're in there,
that there could be any negative
consequences,
something like that.
And this is kind of the fundamental
tragedy of any kind of policy,
especially when it becomes enshrined by
an organization like powerful
organization,
like the American Heart Association or
say our government.
They do what they think they make,
kind of make a best guest and they can't
imagine.
What would the unintended consequences
be?
What would be the unintended
consequences of say,
limiting foods with cholesterol in them?
Well,
not eating liver,
not getting iron,
not getting all that meant eliminating
one of the most nutrient dense foods on
the planet from our diets and so many
other things.
As you know,
egg white omelets.
How many egg white Omelets have you?
Yeah,
I'm not into those.
They're real common.
As soon as I found out that there's a
lot of nutrition in the yolk and that's
like one of the healthiest parts of the
egg.
I was so confused.
I was like,
what is,
what's the egg white thing?
Then why is everybody going with egg
white?
Because they're in the year.
So the yolk is where the cholesterol is.
So that's why we stopped,
stopped eating egg yolks and that's the
yolk is also where all the nutrients
are.
Like including things like Lutein and a,
which is for eye health,
brain development.
I mean there's all kinds of things and
things that are Coleen,
uh,
also for brain development that you can
really not easy to find.
You can't find them easily and plant
foods or at all.
And they're crucial to human
development.
So,
you know,
we eliminated these foods.
You know,
it's ironic like the cholesterol,
if cholesterol is essential to every
cell in your body,
we make cholesterol,
we eat cholesterol.
It's part of what,
you know,
isn't,
it's a building block for all of our
hormones and you know,
coupled with cholesterol or all the
nutrients needed to sustain life.
So we eliminated all those foods.
Um,
I notice that you're saying what you're
saying,
but most people when they hear that,
I'm like,
well,
no,
cholesterol is bad.
It gives you a heart attack.
My Dad is on cholesterol drugs.
He's on the statens to keep cholesterol
out of his body.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
well,
it's been like 60 years of all of us,
you know,
all of us believing that fat and
cholesterol are bad for us.
Right?
Believing cholesterol is bad.
You know,
when I started this,
my whole,
this journey for me,
it was,
you know,
as I said,
vegetarian,
been vegetarian for decades,
um,
hadn't eaten a piece of red meat,
hadn't eaten raw butter for decades,
like barely eaten cheese.
I was for ideological reasons or health
reasons,
I,
I wanted to be thin,
like all girls.
I was like,
it started when I was um,
a,
like a late teenager and,
and of course I became fat.
Like
I'm much thinner now as a middle aged
woman effortlessly than I was.
I was all through my young adult years.
I was like 25 pounds overweight,
but I just,
because I eat a high carb diet,
you know,
as a vegetarian,
you're like,
okay,
don't eat them,
don't get you,
go to the mess,
you know,
the dining hall in college,
like,
don't eat the meat,
don't eat the cheese,
don't eat this and you have a salad and
then you're starving.
So then you're like,
okay,
get the bag of m and m's.
And that's what people do.
You know,
they're starving,
you're starving on that diet.
What is say shooting?
What is satiating?
Foods are protein and fat.
I mean,
that's actually been shown in scientific
experiments where they,
uh,
they put stacks of,
did one experiment,
they put it stacks of like pork chops in
front of people and they just said eat,
you know,
don't stop eating,
don't,
and,
and people just could not overeat on
that food.
You,
you fill up on fat and protein.
And they discovered that those
macronutrients are uniquely satiating.
Whereas carbohydrates,
you know,
overeating on cookies,
crackers,
trips,
pasta,
pasta box,
a whole box of cereal.
I mean,
you know,
in my vegetarian days I could,
I could eat a box of cereal,
no problem.
I'll eat a big bowl of pasta on the days
that I do cheat and even though I'm
stuffed,
I'll still keep eating.
I'll just see there's more left,
is more left.
No one's going to eat that.
I mean that.
I'll just put it in my bowl and just
keep eating.
Just your body craves it in some weird
way.
Well,
or alternatively,
like another physiological explanation
is that your body keeps eating because
it's,
it still hasn't gotten what it needs.
It hasn't gotten the,
the,
the nutrients that it actually needs
for,
to,
to build the cells to,
you know,
you're not giving it what it needs until
you eat the right foods.
Is it possible that both things are
going on that your,
your,
your body hasn't gotten what its needs,
what it needs.
So there's that craving,
but then there's also this incredibly
intoxicating carbohydrate thing going on
where as you're eating it in your just
your sugar levels are getting and you
just want to
keep going.
So what you're talking about I think is
a little bit more like the glucose
rollercoaster that happens and that is
part of carb addiction than the.
And what that is,
is you eat carbs,
really any kind of carbs because.
So I'm talking about bread,
pasta,
you know,
even healthy whole grain bread,
putting little air quotes around
healthy,
um,
and,
and m and ms and snickers bars,
whatever,
whatever you want.
Any of those foods,
when you eat them,
they're converted in your blood into
glucose.
Okay?
Glucose is a simple sugar in your.
It goes around in your blood and,
and,
and it's like a quick fuel and your body
uses that up and then when it's gone you
want another hit.
Um,
and so that's the side,
that's the roller coaster.
So like you have cereal and Oj for
breakfast.
Oj is another just simple sugar and then
by mid morning you're starving,
right?
Whereas,
um,
I think maybe your listeners,
I think you've talked about this on your
program before,
but if you become what's called a fat
burner,
which is somebody who,
your primary fuel is not glucose.
It's fat with the fat in your body that
you store in your body and also the fat
that you eat,
right?
So you think about like a hybrid car.
You can have two fuel sources as a human
being.
You can either live on glucose or fat.
If you've got a healthy metabolism,
you can switch back and forth between
them.
Right?
So I'm,
I'm,
uh,
I've trained my body to,
to be a fat burner,
right?
So I can live off of fat.
It's like I can be the electric car,
but when I,
you know,
when I eat carbs then I can switch over
to glucose,
but I'm healthy enough to switch back,
but unhealthy people who are unhealthy
and or just been living on carbs for
really long time,
mainly glucose,
they can only.
They can only get their fuel from
glucose and if they don't have glucose,
they just bonk.
That's why like you have,
you know,
long distance runners who are constantly
sticking down those,
those,
what are those called?
Those glucose packs and things.
They can't switch over to fat to burn
their own fat.
Eaton is an amazing thing,
like even an obese person.
Imagine I were like a 300 pound woman.
What are those?
What does that though all that fat on me
that is fuel.
That is like,
that is the miracle of,
of humans to be able to say it's like
having granola bars strapped all over my
body.
Right?
I should be able to access that fuel.
That's my fuel source.
Why do we have fat stores?
Becomes a burden.
It's becomes blocked and I can't access
it because I don't know,
my body doesn't know how to burn fat.
And that's what happens when you live
too long living off of glucose as your
only fuel source.
You cannot switch over and burning your
own fat.
It's like living on top of a well and
not having a bucket to,
to,
to get yourself a drink of water.
And then you,
you know,
and then you,
you,
you just,
uh,
you die of thirst.
I mean,
that's a crazy way to look at the
granola bars dropped all over your body.
But I think that's a good analogy.
That's
why you have fat.
That's my all,
all animals or mammals have fat because,
you know,
what do you do when you're,
it's at night.
You don't,
you're not eating all night long.
You have to have fat on your body,
right?
Know,
that's to live off of something.
And that's how humans.
And that's why,
uh,
you know,
humans became really good at,
um,
at storing fat because it meant we could
do other things.
We're not like chimpanzees who have to
eat all day long,
right?
Right.
Or like these people who are fruitarians
and like proud of living off of fruit.
They have to eat all day long to to have
like that's what they have to do all
day,
but we we nutrient dense food like we
meet that humans evolved to eat meat,
so that's nutrient dense so we don't
have to eat all day long,
so we have time on our hands.
We have time in our hands,
do podcasts,
build the Taj Mahal,
do other stuff because we don't have to
eat all the time and we can live off of
our fat.
If we are eating well,
well the idea that you're all that,
that burdens you so where you're.
You have this gut or you have this fat
all over your body and depresses you.
That literally the change,
the point of view,
the perspective that,
look at that as fuel.
You literally have fuel hanging off your
body.
You just have to figure out a way to get
your body to access that and it will
literally eat it away.
Did you ever see rob wolf was talking to
us about,
there was a study where they took a man
who is severely obese and they had him
fast,
nothing but water and some sort of
vitamins for 300 plus days and he wound
up losing not just all the fat,
but the crazy thing was his skin receded
as well,
and he didn't have the loose skin that
normally is associated with rapid weight
loss.
So when you get someone who's incredibly
obese and they shrink down to a normal
size person,
one of the things they have to deal with
routinely as these giant flops of skin
because your body's used to being so
big,
but apparently,
at least in this one case,
this guy,
as he had gone through this enormous
medically controlled fasting,
his skin shrank as well.
Like his body ate the fat and in,
in recognizes that in his body was
shrinking.
Everything sorta shrank up in
proportion.
Well,
that's amazing.
It is amazing.
I wonder if that could be replicated or
if he was just very uniquely,
uh,
had unique genetics or what the
circumstances were.
Some skin varies,
right?
That's why some people get stretch marks
if they just gain a little bit of weight
and other people don't.
Yeah,
I don't know.
I mean,
I think that this is,
you know,
one of the theories behind intermit,
I mean dramatic fasting like that is
just for anybody thinking about it is,
you know,
that's potentially dangerous.
So it has to be medically supervised,
but you know,
people,
there's intermittent fasting that people
do where they fast for a,
you know,
for like I do,
I never eat before noon.
So,
um,
and,
and people do it for a little bit longer
periods of time and it sort of,
um,
induces a state.
What it does is it kickstart this
ability for your body to get into fat
burning mode and to stay in fat burning
mode.
And so,
you know,
what you want to do is you want to,
if you have excess fat on your body,
you want to,
you want to live off of that fat so
it'll disappear.
You want to,
instead of taking in food is your fuel
source.
You want to live off your fat until you,
you,
you know,
until it's gone or the love of it is
gone that you're happy.
So,
and that's what fat burners do.
And the way to do that is to keep carbs
low because carbohydrate moment,
you have glucose in your blood system,
your body prefers glucose.
It's a quick hit of fuel,
right?
Your Body will always prefer glucose and
once you have glucose circulating in
your blood,
it's like a,
it's like going up,
if it's like a being at a teller's
window in a bank,
it's like everything shuts down or like
you cannot get to your fat cells for
psych.
We're closed now.
You can't get to your fat as long as
you've got glucose,
that's what you're living off of.
So the longer your body to do that
because it prefers glucose,
glucose is your preferential fuel source
just is.
I don't know it because it was rare,
you know,
occasionally would come across honey or
it was,
um,
it's,
it was just,
it's a,
it's a quick,
efficient source of fuel.
Um,
so your body came to prefer to prefer
it.
But once you,
so you want to stay away from glucose in
order to access your fat,
that's just the reality.
And so fasting is partly doing that.
You can do it for a little while,
you can do it,
you know,
just if you just fast in the mornings,
your body is basically fast at all night
long.
You fast through the morning and then
you have,
you've,
your,
your fat burning,
all that time.
Most people are not aware of that,
you know,
this is a relatively new situation.
Um,
uh,
I practice it.
I do intermittent fasting.
I do a,
I have a 14 hour window at night where I
don't eat.
And I think the more people do that,
the more they understand that your body
will burn off way more fat if you just
live like that.
If you just force yourself to only eat
inside of a 10 hour window.
Yeah.
So the key to that is you can't be
eating a lot.
You can't be on a high carb diet.
And then fast.
If you're used to eating a lot of carbs,
your body will still preferentially need
those need that glucose.
And you'll still be on that roller
coaster glucose cycle.
So it's,
it's,
I,
I dunno,
I think it's pretty hard to do fasting
when you're in a high carb diet.
And you're right,
this is all pretty.
This is all new science.
So just to,
you know,
if you want to a little bit of
perspective on this.
I'm
really all this science started in the
early two thousands,
um,
and it started.
So,
so the long history is so 1961 American
heart association tells all of America
stop eating fat and cholesterol so you
don't die of a heart attack,
right?
That was heart disease had risen from
pretty much out of nowhere.
And in the early 19 hundreds become the
leading,
leading killer in America.
President Eisenhower himself is out of
the Oval Office for 10 days with a heart
attack.
I mean,
it's just a huge public health
emergency.
And this,
um,
ancil keys,
this a professor at University of
Minnesota,
he came up with this idea that he and
mark hegsted,
the one from Harvard,
said it was,
it was saturated fat and cholesterol
that causes heart disease.
And so that's,
that's when that whole hypothesis was
born and it became enshrined as policy.
The federal government gets on board in
1980 and that's the beginning of our
dietary guidelines.
So now the whole country is not only
avoiding saturated fat and cholesterol,
but also at this point,
all of fat suspects.
So it's like just cut back on all fat
and that was a different reason.
That's because fat is,
um,
is just denser.
Uh,
it has more calories per gram.
It has about nine calories per gram
versus protein and fat,
which have,
I'm sorry,
yes,
protein and carbohydrate,
which have about four or five calories
per gram.
So it was just thought prudent look,
one way to keep people thin is just to
keep their calories down.
And we can do this just by reducing fat
because fat is,
has more calorie dense.
So now we're all in the low fat diet and
we're avoiding saturated fat and
cholesterol and the,
you know,
the government is enormously powerful.
And so,
um,
as I think,
you know,
and so it's not just that all Americans
are given this diet,
right?
All Dr everybody,
every,
every health professional on the front
line,
every dietician,
every medical doctor,
every nutritionist is pushing this low
fat diet,
but all cattle across the country are
bred to be leaner.
The whole food supply changes,
right?
Food's all sorts of low fat foods appear
in the supermarkets.
Everything goes low fat and people
dramatically changed the way they eat.
I mean,
just to give you some numbers like we 34
percent less beef than we did in 1970.
We about 25 percent less red meat
overall wheat,
79 percent less whole milk.
Uh,
we,
you know,
we let,
I think about 19 percent less animal
fats altogether.
Eggs are down.
I mean everything,
all animal foods came down and we
dramatically increased grains.
We eat 30 percent more carbohydrates,
carbohydrates overall,
40 percent more grains,
almost 90 percent more vegetable oils.
These,
of course,
if you're not eating saturated fats,
you're eating polyunsaturated vegetable
oils.
So we had this huge change in the way
Americans eight and 1980 is also.
So that's the beginning of the dietary
guidelines for all Americans.
It's also the beginning of the obesity
epidemic.
You see,
obesity rates of obesity kind of very
slowly,
gradually going up until 1980 and then
they start the,
just take a sharp turn upwards and they
have,
you know,
barely.
I'm barely stopped.
So in the early two thousands,
uh,
what happened?
Well,
a journalist named Gary Taubes wrote
this front page,
New York Times magazine articles saying,
you know,
what,
if,
what if it's all been a big fat lie and
basically kind of revives the idea of
the Atkins Diet and says,
you know,
the Atkins high fat,
low carb,
he had been,
he had promoted his diet from the early
19 seventies on,
but he had really been vilified and
everybody thought he was a quack.
Um,
and at that point there really was no
science to support him.
I mean,
he would say,
but look,
I've,
you know,
I've healed all these people and look at
all my medical files,
go through my drawers,
look at my office.
And everyone would say,
you know,
that doesn't matter what,
there are no clinical trials,
there's no science behind your diet.
Um,
but Gary Taubes came out with this
article and then he came out with a book
in 2007 and a lot of people read his
work.
I mean even though he was vilified and
attacked and he,
but he was brave and a lot of scientists
read his work and a lot of scientists
who thought,
you know,
something is going wrong in America,
our obesity type two diabetes is up.
None of the explanations that we have
are working.
The low fat diets not working for it to
just rates continue to rise.
And so scientists typically not in the
field of nutrition because in the field
of nutrition it's considered heresy
still to research the low carb diet.
Still a.
But scientists from different
disciplines started to do controlled
clinical trials on car reduction,
carbohydrate reduction,
the opposite of the low fat diet,
the opposite of what the government was
telling people to eat.
And so they're starting to develop this
body of clinical trial research.
And there are now nearly a hundred
randomized controlled clinical trials on
this low carb diet.
Um,
and they,
you know,
all kinds of different populations and
they really consistently show that it
not only helps people lose weight and
that was always known even the days of
rob of Atkins,
right?
But people always thought,
oh yeah,
I'll get my waistline,
but you know,
I'll pay for it with a heart attack down
the line and they're just kill my heart
because of the cholesterol.
But it turns out that the Diet is also
the best way to control your blood
glucose for diabetes.
It's,
it helps people.
There's actually an experiment out now
showing that it reverses diabetes.
I mean completely eliminates that
supposedly incurable disease and that it
improves most of the risk factors for
heart disease.
So there's a lot of debate over which
risk factors best predict your
likelihood of getting a heart attack.
But you know,
for the ones that I think are the most
reliable,
including your triglycerides,
your hdl over your triglyceride ratio,
which we don't have to get into that.
But for the,
for,
for the most reliable,
uh,
heart disease risk factors that best
predict heart attacks,
the low carb diet also best improves
those risk factors.
So what was it that made this so taboo
in the food industry
or the food research?
So like if health researchers today
wanted to research low carb diet,
and you're saying that it's taboo,
what's causing that with all of this
body of evidence that you discussed?
All these clinical trials is a,
obviously not just Gary Tobbs with so
many people have talked about this.
Dom D'agostino has done a lot of
research on it and it's,
it's very public.
A lot of people talked about this.
So with all that data,
where is the resistance coming from?
Well,
you know,
so if the low carb diet,
it works and is a healthier diet,
that means the government,
the government's diet,
the low fat diet is making people sick
and fat,
right?
So the entire establishment,
I see,
I'm not talking so not just the
government,
but every university with all their
professors who have been endorsing this
diet and their entire careers.
Um,
all of pharmaceutical companies that
depend on lowering your cholesterol.
I mean there's a huge,
a huge set of interests that are
invested for any number of reasons for
keeping this establishment diet,
for,
you know,
for not backing off this,
this diet that they have prescribed to
the American people for 50 years.
You know,
it's just a huge set of interest.
It's all the companies that benefit from
the Diet,
you know,
vegetable oil companies,
all the companies that produce all the
grains.
I mean 80 percent of things on
supermarket shelves are basically made
out of vegetable oils and grains,
some formulation or another insult.
And so,
you know,
all those companies,
all the universities and then all their
new entire nutrition departments who've
been publishing for 30 years about the
benefits of this diet.
I'm the federal government and all the
men,
the medical professional associations
who have been prescribing this diet to
their patients and their,
you know,
their publics,
the American Heart Association.
I mean it's just,
we're in a situation where we just made
a gigantic mistake.
Wasn't there a recent,
very,
very controversial.
And I'm a,
not just controversial,
but very flawed piece by the American
Heart Association where they were
talking about the dangers of coconut
oils and saturated fats and,
and all those researchers that have been
studying this stuff over the last
decade.
I'm like,
what are you talking about?
Like,
where's this coming from?
Well,
yeah,
I mean,
right now in the nutrition world,
you have people like me who are
challenging the status quo and you have
the sort of the conventional with the
defenders of the conventional wisdom,
uh,
you know,
doubling down to defend their position
is the position of the American or the
American heart association.
The American Heart Association launched
this whole thing in 1961 right there at
the original authors.
So just last year they came out with the
presidential advisory unsaturated fats
were.
They said,
please ignore all those confusing,
you know,
Internet crazies.
I mean,
basically referring to people like me
and Gary Taubes,
you know,
about saturated fats.
We just want to set the record straight
on saturated fats.
And,
you know,
here's our latest affirmation of our,
um,
our belief that saturated fats cause
heart disease.
So,
um,
I want to get too much into the weeds on
dol,
but you know,
they had the way that the American heart
association all these years has
sustained their position that saturated
fats cause heart disease is they have
relied purely on this week kind of
evidence called epidemiology.
Right.
Um,
and,
and the government knew that that was
not strong enough evidence.
So to explain what that means.
Yeah.
Okay.
So an epidemiology or these big studies
where they observe people,
they observe like tens of thousands of
people for a really long period of time
and they,
they asked them,
they just give these people a food
frequency questionnaire and they ask
you,
okay,
how many pairs did you read over the
last six months and how many prunes did
you eat and how much of this did you
eat?
How much of that?
And then you're supposed to write this
all down,
like as if any of us can remember what
we ate yesterday and you're supposed to
make accurate assessments about what
you've eaten on.
Like they asked 250,
the most famous one there just out of
Harvard as 250 questions about what
you've eaten over the past six months.
Now when they try to go and verify to
see if those food frequency
questionnaires are accurate,
they,
they come up,
they basically,
it's very poor accuracy by their own
measures,
but still they use that data and then
they tie.
They follow these people over 10,
20,
30 years and they figure out who has a
heart attack,
who dies,
who gets cancer,
and then they try to make these
correlations.
Oh,
you know,
the people who died tended to eat more
meat.
So they'll say it's meat that caused,
you know,
the what they can really only say if
there's a correlation there,
but it's not causation.
You could never establish causation,
which is to say that caused that death
problem is also that they're eating a
lot of things with that meat.
Right?
So carbohydrates.
Well,
yeah,
I mean like who eats red meat other than
an Paleo people now,
I mean,
who's been eating red meat for the last
50 years?
The people who ignore everything their
doctor tells them,
right?
So not only eating more red meat,
but they're eating a lot of other junk.
They're probably,
you know,
they're probably they,
and this has actually been shown,
they don't exercise as much.
They,
um,
they tend to not eat as well.
They don't visit their doctors,
they don't take their pills.
I mean,
they're not what we would call
compliers,
right.
There are people who just do not listen
to the advice they're given and any
number of those things may have caused
the heart attack.
So we don't know if it's the meat.
We didn't know if it's the noncompliant.
We don't know if it's the lack of
exercise.
We didn't know if it's the fact that
they,
you know,
they drink too much beer,
whatever.
We just don't know.
So those kinds of studies,
these epidemiological studies are really
just,
they,
they only established associations and
way they were designed to suggest
hypotheses that could then actually be
tested.
And a kind of science called a clinical
trial where you actually,
you,
you divide the group up into two parts
and you get like a drug trial,
you give half people to drug and half
people with placebo and only that kind
of experiment,
which is called a controlled experiment.
Can you actually establish cause and
effect.
So the way you want to,
if you really want to know meat causes
cancer,
you got to do a clinical trial,
give half people,
make them meet just red meat all day
long.
And the other half can be on the Vegan
Diet and see,
see who gets cancer,
see which group gets cancer.
Then you're testing,
you're doing actual test.
Um,
so the government just back to this idea
of sat unsaturated fat and then I'll get
back to that presidential advisory.
The government actually did do a whole
bunch of really big expensive randomized
controlled clinical trials on saturated
fat and cholesterol.
They did this on tens of thousands of
people and they they tested to see if
giving the people who ate saturated fat
and cholesterol more of that would die
faster or get a heart attack faster and
none of those clinical trials could
actually show that the people who ate
more saturated fat and cholesterol at
any higher rates of heart disease.
Music.
Is your phone ringing,
your phone going off with music?
I'm sorry.
I was trying to figure out what I
thought.
Maybe the Sonos was kicking off in the
background.
That's your phone musical ringer.
It's okay.
It was just slightly distracting.
So keep going,
please.
Do you want me to resay that?
Okay,
go ahead.
Sure.
Um,
so the government actually did a bunch
of randomized controlled clinical trials
on tens of thousands of people testing
to see if saturated fat and cholesterol
caused heart disease.
They actually took groups of people and
they did this in mental hospitals where
they totally control the people.
Eight and half the people that gave you
know,
meat,
butter,
cheese,
regular high saturated fat and
cholesterol diet and half the people,
they gave them soy filled cheese.
And margarine instead of butter,
and you know,
in soy filled meat and in those
randomized there's rigorous experiments
on tens of thousands of people they
could not show that the people eating
the meat and the butter and cheese died
faster of,
of,
of from heart disease,
died,
died at higher rates from heart disease.
In fact,
they showed in one of the most famous
experiments called the Minnesota
coronary survey.
This survey on on 9,000 men and women
over four and a half years,
they found the more the men lowered
their cholesterol,
the more likely they were to die of a
heart attack.
So what happened to all those
experiments?
They were not.
That particular experiment wasn't
published for 16 years.
Other experiments I've found sat in Nih,
National Institute of Health Basement,
never published,
ignored,
not included in,
in literature,
reviews of that included,
just ignored or suppressed.
It's like out of a crime novel.
It's crazy.
It's.
And so what was the American Heart
Association doing?
Ignoring all those clinical trials.
So the American heart association is
basically just a,
almost protecting their incorrect
statements of the past.
That's what they're doing.
So,
right.
And so this latest presidential advisory
was their attempt because my book a
listed all these clinical trials and
Gary's book did earlier too,
but people have now been talking about
them a lot more in saying like,
how can you ignore that,
that we did all that.
We spent the government spent a billion
dollars more than a billion dollars
testing this hypothesis and could not,
could not show it to be true.
And why did you ignore these experiments
for all these years?
So,
um,
so the American presidential advisory
was in an effort to reckon with those
long ignored clinical trials that had
been funded by the government and they
did it in a way that I think was just
totally disingenuous.
And I wrote a response to it where I
kind of regretted it in,
um,
in medscape and asked,
wrote a piece in the La Times about it.
And um,
he knew we're at this point where the,
these,
these esteemed public health
institutions are defending their long
standing yet erroneous positions about
healthy diet.
And then there's like,
people like me on the outside saying,
you know,
and,
and not just me,
you know,
there's now a whole course of scientists
around the world who are saying the same
thing,
you know,
saying these recommendations are based
on flawed evidence.
Our guidelines are not evidenced based.
We need to,
you know,
our national guidelines are not based on
good evidence.
So there's this growing chorus around
the world and,
and,
you know,
I'm one of the voices,
I'm probably one of the more prominent
voices now,
but um,
you know,
we,
we just,
we just have national guidance that's
just not based on good evidence.
There's that.
And then there's a lot of people that
get really confused by audiologically
based documentaries and things that are
trying to push people like what the
health and things along those lines.
They're trying to make some really
unsubstantiated correlations between
meat consumption in diabetes and a bunch
of other like really weird ones that
I've never heard before that I hear
repeated by people.
I'm like,
wait,
where the fuck did you hear that?
And they'll tell me without doubt,
this one documentary,
what?
The health.
Yeah.
I wrote a rebuttal to that too,
which I'm happy to post if you want on
there.
And so,
okay.
So that's a perfect example.
Like what was one of them was,
you know,
eating a,
eating an egg or two a day,
days like smoking five cigarettes,
like crazy stuff.
Right?
So all of that is based on that really
weak epidemiological evidence.
None of it has been either it's not been
tested in clinical trials or the
clinical trials that do not support
those statements.
I went through every single scientific
claim in that movie I did.
I was in Greece on a holiday.
And everybody's like,
why aren't you at the beach?
I'm like,
because I have to go through every
single scientific claim of what the
health and show that it's based on this
really weak,
unsubstantiated evidence.
And,
but you know,
these,
I think that one of the reasons that,
that they made that film was that,
um,
you know,
we live,
we live in very confusing times for
science,
right?
You,
you make a film,
you pull it somebody's heart
heartstrings,
you know,
it's very,
that's film is like,
it's very scary.
You feel like,
oh my God,
there's poison in the milk and now
there's poison in my pregnant belly and
it's going to be in my child.
I mean,
it's really effective as a piece of,
uh,
of,
as a movie.
But isn't it
not just irresponsible but dangerous?
Well,
I think so.
I mean,
but I think that what you have is people
pushing this diet for ideological
reasons as you said,
you know,
they're,
they're the people behind that film or
you know,
two very,
very well known and a animal welfare
activists who just don't want animals
killed.
Um,
and you know,
those are their motivations and there
are other people who are,
um,
have faith.
They have practices or kind of empires.
Like Dean ornish has a whole empire
based on his plant based Diet,
right?
There's just,
there's whole business commercial
empires that are based on this diet.
So the unit as a whole combination of
reasons.
Now there's a part of the,
you know,
in the environmental movement really
believes that cows cause global warming,
so there's like this whole confluence of
interests,
but if you just look at the health
claims,
there are no randomized controlled
clinical trials.
There's no rigorous evidence to show
that that diet is safe or,
or you know,
or can fight disease.
And they've actually,
you know,
a few of these Vegan diet doctors have
actually done clinical trials and there
was where they put people on a Vegan
Diet.
Okay.
So,
and they were overseen by the Vegan
Diet,
Dr himself.
So as John Mcdougal did one of these,
he's,
he is here in California.
So I mean the most biased possible
person overseeing this experiment,
right?
He wants his diet to look good.
Um,
but even then he could,
they,
those,
those studies could not show that,
that the vegans were healthier at the
end of a year of eating that diet.
So maybe it's a healthy diet,
but it cannot be shown to be true.
And so it's fine to eat it for whatever
reason that you want to.
But,
but health,
there's no evidence to show that that
diet will be a good option for health.
Yeah.
That is a very hard pill for a lot of
people to swallow that for good reasons
don't want animals to suffer.
Right?
So they want to live a life where they
have a small footprint as possible and
don't harm things.
One of the things that disturbs people
to no end is when I described the
process of collecting green in a combine
and how vultures will circle over fields
right after the combine rolls over
because those indiscriminate gigantic
machines that might be a football field
wide or just chewing up everything in
front of them,
including ground nesting birds and
squirrels and rodents and occasionally,
dear fons and anything else that gets
caught up in the middle of it.
Yeah.
I mean,
the reality is there is no life for any
creature without the death of another
creature.
I mean,
there's,
um,
life involves death of some kind or
another.
I mean know monocropping agriculture is
devastating to the,
to,
to all kinds of life.
It's also incredibly unnatural.
It's unnatural to see thousands of acres
that are just soybeans.
Right?
That is,
does very,
very weird.
It's not,
it doesn't exist anywhere in the world
other than places where people have
forced that into the environment.
Yeah.
And I think that there's also,
you know,
a deep discomfort with the fact that,
for many people,
um,
any sentience person that being human
has,
you know,
we were,
we evolved eating meat,
right?
We're,
we're,
we're not herbivores.
Um,
and so,
and,
and we can't really survive that way.
In fact,
in the early experiments that they did
on omnivore animals,
um,
they did that,
them on all kinds of,
um,
number animals in the 19 twenties and
thirties.
And they tried to see if they could get
an omnivore animal to survive purely on
plants,
green seeds,
um,
and they,
they found it incredibly difficult to
keep those,
you know,
whether a rats are pigs alive and even
when they could keep them alive,
they live shorter lives and their
offspring live shorter lives.
So,
you know,
we,
we have,
I think,
you know,
we're,
we're ethical beings and so we have a
discomfort with killing other animals as
well as we should.
But um,
you know,
that is why I think humans evolved all
kinds of ways of dealing with,
with the need to kill animals basically
just to survive,
right?
The,
all the rituals,
the asking of forgiveness,
the um,
and of course when it was your own
animals,
we all raised our own people,
raised,
lived on farms and raised their own
animals.
There were ways I,
you know,
that it was a much more,
sort of a part of the holistic
experience of being a farmer and living
on the land.
And now we're all so devoid live in
cities.
We're thousands of miles away from,
from where animals are raised.
We don't really understand anything
about it.
It seems inhumane and cruel.
Getting a
solution for this is probably going to
be this sort of laboratory created meet
that seems to be a flourishing industry
right now.
They're trying to get off the ground
with this stuff and it's very expensive
at the moment,
but they foresee that in the next
several years it'll be economically
feasible for people to buy meat from an
animal that never really existed as a
living thing.
You know,
if they can do that and it has all the
same nutrients that you,
that real animals do,
that would be a miracle,
right?
Yeah,
it would be.
It's gonna be very interesting,
but then there's also the issue of what
happens if we completely stopped eating
cows and chickens and pigs and what
happens to all those animals?
W W who manages that,
who stops them from overbreeding,
who,
who controls their population.
How do we do that?
We've put ourselves into a corner here.
We've put ourselves into a corner.
If we choose to never eat these animals
again,
how do we sustain their populations and
what financial,
what financial reward do people get for
sustaining them?
If they're not going to profit from them
whatsoever,
they're going to have to spend an
exorbitant amount of money or let them
roam free,
which people,
if people don't realize that's happening
in parts of the world,
bowls revert to a very strange form,
a wild cows do in Australia.
They call them scrub bowls.
I mean,
you know,
they live in the scrubs and that these
scrub bowls are incredibly aggressive,
enormous,
weird looking cow things that they now
hunt and uh,
they have a problem with them in certain
parts of Australia because they'll break
into these confined areas where they
have domestic cattle and screw up the
genes of these cattle with these wild
cattle strains.
These bowls are incredibly aggressive
and they just roaming loose and you
know,
is that what we're going to do,
can have wild cows everywhere.
Like,
okay,
so what happens at the wild cow
populations get out of control.
We're going to bring in lions,
like,
what are we doing?
I didn't know.
You know,
and there's,
you know,
this is something that I'm not an expert
in,
but I know people,
you know,
there's a whole school of thought.
You really need large animals.
Um,
you know,
they're part of a,
part of an ecosystem to have a healthy
ecosystem on earth,
you know,
you need animals as part of their,
they return manure to the earth and
that's part of the cycle of life and
that,
you know,
can't,
plants can't survive without him and you
need animals actually to,
uh,
as,
as part of a healthy,
healthy environment.
So,
you know,
that's not something that I'm an expert
in it.
Uh,
but I think it is,
you know,
I,
I guess I would say like the kind of
really simplistic,
it's just simplistic thinking to say
that we should get rid of all animals
or,
you know,
get rid of all domesticated animals.
Yes.
I mean,
I just think that's,
that's a kind of simplistic vision.
That's the
dealing with simplistic versions,
right?
We're dealing with an incredibly
complicated situation we find ourselves
in,
in the 21st century that you didn't ask
for it.
I didn't ask for it,
this is just the place where we were
born and raised,
so then we look around the landscape and
we go,
okay,
what,
what do I have to do for this meet
vehicle?
What do I have to do to keep this thing
optimized and then what do I have to do
for my mind that I don't feel terrible?
How about eating some horrifying factory
farmed food or I have to watch some
video on how this thing was created and,
and realize I'm a monster,
you know,
and I think that is the motivation for a
lot of people to go towards veganism and
I think it's a good motivation.
I think their,
their,
their motivations are noble injust if
that's what they are,
but somewhere along the way you get
roped into an ideology and you get boxed
into these very rigid ways of thinking
and out of those rigid ways of thinking.
You get a documentary.
Like what?
The health.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
I would also,
I also think if we're in the same way
that we're a divided nation politically,
we are a divided nation in terms of the
way we think in urban city centers and
you know,
where I've always lived my whole life,
but um,
and out in the areas of the country,
you know,
the red states where they,
they take,
they,
they have cattle and they,
you know,
the dairy farms are and you know,
this is like,
we,
we actually have no idea for the most
part.
What goes on there.
Um,
and you know,
we just see like the horrifying videos
shot by some undercover person or I mean
it's,
you know,
one of the things that was sort of
surprising and,
and,
and like a really beautiful experience
for me after my book came out was that I
was invited to speak all over the
country.
And you know,
I'm your classic flyover person.
I grew up in Berkeley,
California.
And then,
I mean,
then I lived various places in the
world.
But then I settled in New York City.
So,
you know,
I'm like as urban progressive liberal as
they come and all of a sudden I'm giving
speeches in Oklahoma and Texas and,
you know,
Illinois,
I mean really,
it was,
it was really a shock to me,
but it was truly eye opening.
Like I met all the people who,
you know,
all these people in the cowboy hats were
like,
oh,
I would've,
I would've been one of the ones
protesting,
throwing Kale at these guys know in my
previous life.
And No,
I'm,
you know,
standing in front of 800 of them talking
about saturated fat,
you know,
the findings in my book.
That's what I,
you know,
here's what I've found and you know,
I can't say that I did any kind of in
depth reporting but,
but really the kinds of conversations
that they're having about how to best
take care of their animals,
how to treat them humanely,
how to,
you know,
um,
how to raise fewer cattles and then
produce more.
And I mean,
they're like,
they were really just not the demons
that I thought they were.
And I don't pretend to really know what
goes on in animal agriculture across the
country,
but I just want to say like,
it made me realize how in the same way
that we have this conversation going on
now in the country,
um,
politically the same,
you know,
this is one issue where that plays out.
We have such a,
we have such a lack of understanding and
comfort,
real conversation and understanding
between,
um,
those have on the coasts and the people
who are actually raising the food in the
middle of the country.
So
convenient.
And I do it too.
A lot of people demonize people that
live in places that they don't frequent.
And it's really fun to poke fun at the
middle of the country and call them a
bunch of dummies.
And Yeah,
the reason why trump got elected,
I think it's okay to do that.
You know,
I've noticed in like,
you know,
my,
my colleagues,
you know,
liberal journalists.
I mean,
there's like the way the kind of digs
that they will take at rural white
people is like,
you know,
we,
if that was something about a person of
color or a woman,
I mean sure,
that that person would be kicked out of
their job.
I mean,
it's just amazing the level of a sort of
the accepted kind of stereotyping that
goes on in the media towards these
people who,
you know.
Again,
I,
that would have been me except that I
just had this experience.
Love to like pick your side and then do
you use any means necessary to attack
the other side?
I mean,
you see this in an unreal,
not an unrelated way with the way they
make fun of trump's hands.
Like you're,
you're mocking this man's body.
Like he didn't do anything to have
smaller or bigger hands.
Talk about his hair,
talk about his ego,
talk about the preposterous way he
behaves,
but you're talking about his hands like
that.
You're just saying the gloves are off
and you could do anything you want and
you can just be a cruel person in body
shame.
This guy for something he has absolutely
no control over.
There's plenty of things he's done wrong
that you can make fun of,
but what about all the other people that
are reading about his tiny little hands
and they look down at their own tiny
little hands and they have to feel like
shit.
You know?
I mean that's A.
There's a a weird thing that people do.
It's very.
And use that to tie it all together.
You really see that in the Vegan
community.
There are a lot of vegans who are really
kind people and then there's a lot of
vegans.
I always say that they're only reason
why they're vegans because scientology
didn't find them first.
These motherfuckers would have joined
the Taliban if they took the wrong
flight.
They just.
They found a group and they went with it
and now they are all in and you see that
with a lot of different ideologies,
but with vegans especially online,
they're so vicious and they,
the.
The attacks are so ruthless and they
gang up.
They get together and it's like part of
the fun of being on this gang is
attacking people that disagree and I
know you've been the victim of this.
Yeah,
I mean I think that um,
you know,
I have,
I,
I am sympathetic in the sense that
people are so worried about their health
and there's so much conflicting
information out there and they don't
know how to make of it.
And then there's a kind of.
And we eat,
you know,
you have to eat two or three times a
day.
So this thing is staring you in the
face.
You cannot avoid it and then you find
something that you think is healthy and
good and pure and right and you want and
it becomes an.
And to be a Vegan requires a lot of
work.
Right?
You have to.
I know because when I was a vegetarian I
was like constantly chopping and dicing
and roasting and you know,
it's like a lot of work.
It's a lot harder.
I realized when I started eating meat
you could just put a piece of meat on
the stove and that was it.
I've become a very lazy cook,
um,
but in any case it's,
it is.
People would come very passionate about
their choices and especially a choice
that involves consuming food which is so
personal and intimate.
And then,
um,
it's very hard to,
you know,
to,
to acknowledge that that may not have
been a good choice for you or for your
kids.
Um,
and so,
you know,
I think it's,
but it's,
yeah,
it's become a kind of idea.
I mean,
one of the things that I think has
happened is that,
you know,
we live in post ideological times,
right?
I mean,
you joke about scientology,
but we live in times where people are no
longer members of when we're not as many
people are members of our religious
right in any kind of traditional way.
And food is one thing that people become
religious about.
They just do it.
It's like a food type of thing.
It's a food movement and the food
movement,
I mean if you follow like Michael Pollan
and Mark Bittman and they encourage you
to think about it as a movement,
as something you can join,
be a part of being a community and
it provides everything that,
you know,
really didn't.
Religions did provide for people
full,
but for the vegans,
what they do have on their side is that
they feel that their lifestyle is not
promoting animal cruelty and that gives
them the justification for attacking
someone like you.
Right?
Because.
Right.
Well,
you know,
I try to just stick to.
I mean
I try to really stick to the science on
what makes people healthy so you know,
if,
if you want to be a Vegan,
but if that diet comes with,
um,
you know,
for most people,
if it comes with diabetes and obesity or
ill health or the,
or the failure to thrive if their
children or whatever.
I mean that's their choice.
But you know,
you can't.
Well you can't say is that that diet has
any evidence to show that it provides
good health.
Boy,
I think one thing that a Vegan diet does
is it gets people off of the standard
American diet and the standard American
diet of just a bunch of bullshit French
fries and French fries can be Vegan,
right?
But the,
the,
you know,
the processed food and things with a ton
of preservatives.
You start eating a bunch of vegetables.
I mean,
you're going to probably feel a lot
better.
We start eating actual real foods.
Yeah.
Anybody who gets off of refined
carbohydrates and sugar,
it feels better.
So that is definitely a step in the
right direction.
I mean,
we can all agree on that and that's
processed food,
preservatives,
just eating nonsense and garbage and
candy and just that kind of stuff.
If you can be conscious and proactive
about the healthy foods you choose and
just try to get as much healthy
nutrients as you can,
you're going to feel better.
But the question is what's the best way
to optimize your health?
Yeah,
and just going back to this animal
experiments that I was telling me about
the 19 twenties and thirties,
you know,
what leads to long your long life in the
long life and health of your children,
right?
That's the way we used to think about
survival of health,
fitness of an animal was how long did
you survive and how long do your,
your offspring survive.
Right?
And,
and that,
that was the ultimate measure of,
that's always been the ultimate measure,
evolutionarily.
So you know,
if,
if a Vegan Diet were to support that,
that would,
um,
that would be the optimal diet,
but that,
that was just not what the science
showed.
So,
you know,
I mean,
there's also a whole kind of
evolutionary issue here,
which is you have to,
you have to bring in evolutionary
science to understand and,
you know,
how did humans evolve?
I mean,
we're in a kind of ironic position where
there's so many enlightened progressive
thinkers who are almost like,
um,
you know,
just deny her,
like denying our evolutionary history.
Right?
Um,
they're almost like creationists,
I mean our evolutionary history,
if you read,
if you read the science is about
evolving with meat,
that's just our reality.
So we can't,
you know,
you can't really deny that and say,
we did not spring out of,
you know,
out of the side of Athena or,
whatever.
We,
we,
we evolved.
We evolved because we ate meat there.
Many evolutionary theorists who believe
we evolved only because we ate meat.
Yeah,
the doubling of the human brain size,
which one of the biggest mysteries in
the fossil record over a period of 2
million years of human brain doubled.
And one of the primary ideas is that
cooking meat and then figuring out a way
to hunt these animals made us stimulate
our brains.
And there's a couple of other more
outlandish theories.
One of them involving siliciden
mushrooms,
it's pretty interesting.
But,
um,
it's called the stoned ape theory if you
want to look it up.
But the,
the idea that we are herbivores and you
hear this tossed around a lot and you'll
literally see like Vegan memes that show
our teeth versus a primates teeth or a
rather a,
uh,
a carnivores teeth and showing that we
have teeth to grind up stuff.
But don't.
These are teeth that have evolved for
people that eat cooked food,
right?
I mean,
this is where it's disingenuous.
Like,
no,
first of all,
we do have the teeth,
have an.
And second of all,
we have the teeth,
have an omnivore that has been cooking
food.
We don't need the same kind of teeth we
used to need to tear apart raw meat like
we did 200,000 years ago whenever it
was,
you know,
it's interesting.
One of the things that I explore in my
book is the,
um,
the way that meat has been valued
through human history and it was valued
a bit as the food of warriors.
Um,
and that,
you know,
like the Maasai warriors who were
studied by a biochemist data out of the
University of Vanderbilt in the late 19
seventies called the Messiah Warriors in
Kenya.
And they,
he found that they ate nothing but meat
and blood and milk,
um,
and that was the warrior class and that
was what was considered that made men
strong.
The women were allowed a more diverse
diet,
but the men who had to be strong and had
to hunt,
they had this just purely meat in my
diet.
Um,
and,
and there's another interesting story
about how that same,
um,
tribe was compared to they,
they actually had a kind of vegetarian
tribe nearby.
Um,
and that when they were both called,
when both these tribes were called up
for the Boer war and the English tested
their strength to see whom they could
hire to fight for them.
Um,
and the,
and the vegetarian men from this one
tribe that was,
that this neighboring tried,
they had no strength.
They,
you know,
they tested them to see how that,
that device you use your hand to clench,
see how strong they were.
They found them completely unfit and
unable to do work.
And they weren't strong.
They didn't have the same kind of muscle
mass literally.
So they couldn't use the men from that
tribe.
Um,
and then there's,
you know,
there's just a rich history in
literature about how meat was really the
food that made you strong and meet with
a food that was craved,
always craved that,
that humans craved above all else
would there have been vegan power
lifters and a bunch of different people
that have figured out how to do it
correctly today though,
right?
I think they may have,
but I didn't,
you know,
they must have taken a lot of
supplements and other kinds of soy
proteins or other,
you know,
other things are you have to be.
I mean,
there,
there are,
there are replacements I guess in the
modern food supply,
but um,
you know,
historically based on real foods
available to humans for Millennia,
it was meat that was what was used to be
strong.
Yeah.
And the dirty secret in the Vegan
bodybuilder community is steroids and
steroids were allow you to get away with
a lot of stuff.
And obviously that's the dirty secret
and all the body building communities,
but the Vegan ones,
they want to just pretend everything.
Oh,
look on a plant based Diet.
Look at my amazing body,
sorta.
Yeah,
you definitely.
I mean,
yeah,
but that other stuff,
you know,
I mean,
this is something that gets extremely
ignored where it's way more open and out
in the,
uh,
non Vegan bodybuilding community.
Yeah.
Because I'm deep into the body,
but I know you brought it up.
I know what you're saying.
W,
w what have you,
out of all this research and all this,
uh,
analyzing this and the,
you know,
the publishing of your book and the way
it's been received.
How,
how has this changed the way you think
about the way people approach,
not just diet but all sort of conflicts
in life?
Oh,
that's a big question.
I mean,
I'm,
there are a couple of
major ways this profoundly,
this whole research changed my thinking.
One.
Um,
so one was really that I,
it changed my thinking about,
uh,
it changed my political views quite a
bit.
Um,
I think you are,
you're a libertarian or at least that's
what I was reading about you.
I was always,
I mean,
I grew up in Berkeley and was a real,
um,
like Liberal Democrat and still am on
most issues,
but you know,
here I found an issue where the
government had started this program of
telling Americans how to eat and just
made this huge giant mistake and this,
you know,
spent hundreds and hundreds of billions
of dollars on this program that,
you know,
we have quite a bit of evidence now I
think to make a pretty good case that
the government made America started the
obesity and diabetes epidemics and
continue and don't back down from their
recommendations even though they
continue to do this.
And so,
you know,
this is the one government program that
I have researched in great depth.
I haven't really looked into too many
else in anything else in the kind of
incredible level of detail that I have.
This one.
And it made me,
I'm much more cautious about supporting
big government programs.
I'm not because I don't believe in
government.
I do.
I mean,
I,
I believe that humans need to govern
themselves wisely and it shouldn't just
be,
you know,
we shouldn't have government,
but the potential to make mistakes,
the power of government to that once it,
once it adopts a hypothesis or an idea
of some kind,
and then the incredible institutional
entrenchment that happens when you adopt
a certain view,
right?
And then it's so hard to reverse out of
that particular chosen line of thinking,
it becomes almost impossible.
You know,
this institutions are not built for
that.
They're not really built for science.
You know,
science is supposed to be,
as I said earlier,
self-doubting self questioning of new
observations.
So you change your course.
That's what science is supposed to be
like you,
you test things and they don't work out
and then you move on to another idea.
But an institution is,
is it's,
it's almost like institutional sciences
click an oxymoron because an institution
is meant to not flip on their publics,
not to change their views,
not to lose,
not to allow people to lose faith in
them.
So it's,
it's there,
that's,
it's the wrong kind of body to do
science.
Um,
so it's made me much more,
a much more cautious about how much I
want our government to do,
um,
because if I have just turned over this
one little leaf and found this huge
disastrous program,
uh,
you know,
I just wonder if I'd turned over any
other leaf.
What,
uh,
what,
what else would I find?
I think you'd find similar in competence
probably.
Yeah.
So,
um,
so it's changed my political thinking
quite a bit.
Um,
and then I think it's also,
you know,
when I see the way that the scientific
debate is played out and I,
and you know,
I know the science so intimately now,
um,
you know,
I know I've read every single nutrition
experiment that has really been done
since the mid fifties.
And,
you know,
when I see the way the debate plays out
in public,
you know,
I see that a American heart association,
Presidential Advisory,
which I just see as a,
you know,
it's,
it's not honest science or our last
dietary guidelines,
expert committee in their report saying,
you know,
we should,
um,
we should all eat a plant based diet.
And I,
you know,
I can see how bad that science is.
And so,
you know,
I see that,
that I can see now so much better the,
the,
the way that I'm PR firms,
spin messages and the way those messages
are echoed all over and the way,
you know,
it's just the way it's what's happening
in our politics.
It's,
it's happening in our science.
Um,
and,
and so I think it makes me somewhat
despair about our ability to have good
science rise to the top.
Because,
you know,
when you have institutions like Harvard
and tufts and you know,
all of our top institutions are so
deeply invested in this wrong
hypothesis.
Yet I don't even know.
I don't know where people should turn
to,
you know,
how,
how do we sort ourselves out of this
mess?
Um,
so yeah,
nutrition science is in bad shape and I,
and it,
it changed my,
it's changed my faith in expert advice.
Maybe that's the bottom line.
I really don't trust expert advice
because I see the way it is manipulated,
um,
by financial interests and professional
interests and intellectual conflicts of
interest.
And so,
you know,
even little tiny things like anything,
a warning label on a bottle,
like,
you know,
careful of this plastic or this or that.
I'm like,
I don't believe anything unless I go
back to their original science and read
it all myself,
which I can never do.
I just don't trust anything anymore.
That's not a good place to be.
It isn't.
I need to spend time in your isolation
tank
boy.
And with that,
um,
if people want to find out more,
your book,
a big fat surprise.
What else?
So my book is called the big fat
surprise.
It's available on Amazon.
I have my website is [inaudible] dot
com,
which is,
you'll never be able to spell,
but if you look up the big fat surprise,
you'll get to Nina titles and um,
and I also started a group called the
nutrition coalition,
which is nutrition coalition dot u s
that is a group that is backed by
scientists,
phds,
mds.
The odd journalists like me.
Um,
we are basically the work of that group
is to try to ensure that our nutrition
policy is evidenced based,
right?
Trying to unearth that,
suppress the science,
get those studies out of the nih
basement,
that kind of thing.
Just to ensure that whatever the,
if the government is going to tell
Americans what to eat,
it needs to be evidenced based.
Um,
so we're doing work in Washington and
um,
and you can read about,
I mean it's not just on fat and
carbohydrates that I've got.
They've got it wrong on Salt,
you know,
the advice to get aerobic exercise for
45 to minutes to an hour every day.
None of that is based on good science.
So we just want the,
the goal of this group is to work
towards evidence based policy in
nutrition
two.
So please talk a little bit more about
salt because that's one that comes up
all the time with people.
They want to tell me that salt's bad for
you.
I'm like,
goddammit,
salt is an essential nutrient.
You'll die without it.
So
the short story and salt is that they
did a bunch of clinical trials only on
hypertensive subjects.
So anybody that were already sick,
okay.
So if you're a normal person,
if you're child,
if you're a you,
none of this applies to you should never
have been generalized to a larger
population.
They were called the Dash Studies.
None of these studies were longer than
two months,
which is super short for clinical trial.
And what they showed was that for people
who already had hypertension and eight,
a lot of salt,
the,
for those people reducing their salt
improved their,
um,
their cardiovascular risk factors.
They didn't follow any of these people
long enough to figure out who actually
had heart attack or died.
They're very,
very short term,
small experiments.
They never tested more than 2000 people
on them.
This,
this whole dash died,
this reduced sodium diet.
None of that advice should be
generalized to anybody else.
And there have now been for large
studies where they,
um,
their epidemiological studies so that
they're not,
that's only associations,
but the important thing about it is that
there's,
they contradict this salt advice.
They show that really if you go too low,
people who consumed too little salt,
those people,
uh,
have higher rates,
higher rates of cardiovascular death,
so that there seems to be a sweet spot
for consuming salt starts the,
it's sort of aj shaped curve.
So if you have moderate consumption of
salt for the general population is a,
is,
is sort of the sweet spot for,
for a good and cardiovascular health.
So and so,
you know,
the government's advice is lower is
better for all Americans and that's just
not based on any good,
any rigorous science at all.
Boom,
boom.
So our group is working to try to change
that,
you know,
it just has to change
without people like you.
People like me would be completely lost.
So thank you so much for all your
research.
Thank you for your book.
Thank you for your time here on the
podcast.
I appreciate it.
And people please go out buy her book.
Is there anything else you could
recommend people check into?
They can.
They can donate to the nutrition
coalition if they want the dietary
guidelines to change and I'll just put a
little plug for that because the reason
they have to change,
they control school lunches,
military rations,
food in hospitals,
food and elderly homes.
Everything your doctor tells you,
your intuition is telling you.
They're like,
that's where it all comes from.
So that's it.
Thanks for letting me.
Thank you.
Thanks for having me.
Bye everybody.